(upbeat music)
- So if you look at Dark
Star it's sort of like
a comedic student
version of Alien 'cause
Dan O'Bannon who wrote
Alien wrote Dark Star and--
- Oh don't get me
started on O'Bannon.
- O'Bannon's the best.
You actually have a Dan
O'Bannon-ness about you.
- Thank you.
- You really sort of look
very Dan O'Bannon-ish.
(laughs)
- Eli, great, I can
see we're out of time.
Thanks, you, oh my god.
- It was a great like
nerding out with you.
- Oh my god, I could
do this all day long.
- I'm actually cooking
something pretty cool right now.
It's a new movie where a film
journalist is taken hostage.
So it's like you're
literally the
first person I'm telling it to.
- That sounds like
an amazing idea.
- Yeah should be fun,
yeah tell your friends.
Yeah no, seriously,
let your friends know.
If you have any friends
that want to be movie stars.
- Oh yeah?
SO he tells me it's
about a movie reporter
who's taken hostage, right?
And so he looks at me and he
says hey, tell all your friends
because I'm casting this today.
- What the fuck
did you just say?
- And that's a big
deal I take it?
- Yeah, off camera, yeah.
- You're so new.
- It's the real deal.
- Yeah that's what I'm
saying, guys, it's true!
It's probably going to be
like a whole franchise.
- Well of course it
is, Captain Doughnut.
Listen, if he thinks
I'm not getting
points on this
thing, he is a fool.
And Britney, you know how
much I value the back end.
(laughs)
- Ha ha gross.
- Don't fucking touch me.
- Can we just be serious
here for a minute?
All right, if I'm not
mistaken I'm the only person
here who's done a two episode
arc on Franklin and Bash.
You guys remember
it, I was very good.
Breckin Meyer, good friend
of mine said I was sublime.
- Guys, the fact
of the matter is,
one of our lives is
gonna change today.
Right Christopher?
- Okay baby let's take a selfie.
Oh my god are you okay?
- I get it, I have
like great teeth,
I never had braces,
my skin's perfect,
my eyes are beautiful,
I'm definitely touched
by the hand of Jesus, but like--
- You're so handsome.
- I've really had
this secret dream
of being an actor, you know?
And my parents they've
never supported it.
- Oh honey.
Your parents sound
like assholes.
- I'm just feeling really
ugly, I don't know.
It's just--
- Okay Christopher?
You're one of the most
beautiful men I've ever
laid eyes on and I'm including
myself in a man's wig.
I'm gonna get real
with you for a second.
If you want to be an
actor, be an actor.
If you want to be a garbage
man, be a garbage man.
You know what I'm saying though?
You need to get out there and
you need to take what's yours
because you only live
once, as far as we know.
- You're a lifesaver.
- Stop, you're so cute.
I love you so much.
- I love you.
- I'm like in love with you.
- I'm in love with you,
no, no, but just not.
- Okay sorry.
- Just like, I'm gonna do it.
- Go, go, yolo!
That's good, I
should hashtag yolo.
Has anyone ever done that?
- Hey buzz buzz buzz.
Christopher David, yes
I'm absolutely an actor.
- I wanted to make
something that was more
in the Tarkovsky Solaris--
- Enough about
that for a second.
Do you get a chance to
watch any of the stuff
they're doing over at TNT?
Franklin and Bash,
you seen any of that?
It's really good.
- No, I've been a
little busy lately.
- Dylan McDermott
Dermot Mulroney
Dylan McDermott Dermot Mulroney.
Hello, my name is
Benedict Cumberbatch.
- I really wanted to
do something that was
somewhere between a mix
of Blair Witch and--
- Let me just give you this.
I was also playing myself
in Step Up 3D, information
on the back and good
luck with this project.
It looks terrific, it's cute.
- You're a young James Franco.
You're Dave Franco.
Oh yeah, you're Zac Ef,
no you're Dave Franco.
This is the day.
Shit!
- It's interesting because--
I hear that you're
kind of looking
for the next big star
for your next film?
- Obviously Decker talked
to some other people.
- Yeah he sure did.
- James Franco
buddy, look at you.
You're like a mirror.
Fuck!
- I love horror, I
love science fiction--
- I was voted most likely to
get murdered in high school.
- You were?
- I don't know if
you're planning any
other horror movies.
- You sort of need a
good horror movie scream.
- I have that.
- Can I hear it?
- Yes.
(screams)
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- Shut up!
(sobs)
God damn it!
- Yeah I'm looking
for Christopher.
Hey hey, Christopher
are you in there?
I can hear something.
What are you doing in there?
Okay, get me when you're out.
- Hey.
- Christopher David.
- Hi.
Oh god, does anyone
have a towel?
- It's the buzz.
- Purell, is my
Purell over there?
- Buzz buzz buzzes,
Christopher David here.
- Hey.
(clears throat)
- Buzz--
- Do you have a question?
Do you want me, why
don't I just start?
Let me tell you
about Mission Fear.
I'm so excited--
- Yeah I've got
questions for you.
Okay Eli.
- Do you, you know a lot of
people don't know this about me,
but I've always
wanted to do sci-fi.
It's like been
this secret dream.
(laughs)
- Secret dream, is that
what you just said?
(laughs)
It's your secret dream.
Oh my god it's
your secret dream.
- Christopher, please
let Eli Roth out!
- Hey what's going on you guys?
- Christopher went
nuts in there.
He's holding him hostage.
Don't you hurt my Eli!
- Not to make this about me,
but I feel like this
might be my fault.
I accidentally told
Christopher he was important.
- Why would you do that?
- Hey have you guys
seen my phone charger?
- Shut up, shut up!
- Okay watch out, watch out.
- Ha ha wow, what a
talent this guy is.
- Big news!
Sounds like I'm going to
be signing up for IMDB pro.
I booked it!
- Yes you did, okay
we're just gonna
take it down a notch, okay?
Get his ass!
- Fuck you Eli Roth.
- Fuck you you fucking
discount Jay Hernandez.
(gasps)
- Does this mean the
role's still up for grabs?
- Secret dream!
- Is he saying see my penis?
That's weird.